i was thinking about the first time i
met you was before friends even went on
the air yes it was 94 and your show was
gonna that was 19 years ago oh my god
yeah and your show was a we were at the
riga royale right lisa kudrow and i've
been lifelong friends with lisa kudrow
and she said uh we're i'm launching this
new show right with my friend uh
jennifer aniston and i was like good
luck with that uh
who
yeah
i know how to pick them and i said this
isn't going anywhere kids
but i went and met you i remembered we
had like a breakfast with you yes
exactly and you were very you were very
tall
very
red tall hair
that's the nicest thing anyone's ever
said about me but it was i wasn't very
impressed with this very tall
and it became your thing so it came out
i was like it became your logo you know
you're yeah
we worked i remember it has i remembered
at uh it's funny because uh what's today
yeah today's thursday today's tuesday
back me up here crowd
really
you know you have a good crowd when
they're cheering that we know that they
know the day of the week
uh on tuesday uh lisa kudrow was here
and she said
that uh there was a recent hoax about a
friend's a possible friend's reunion
yeah that like went
viral and it had a lot of people
believing it lisa said even she believed
it for like she said for like an hour
she was like i guess they didn't ask me
that's hysterical but i have to tell you
i heard that story
uh and actually i oddly enough had a
dream last night that that actually
happened to me that that that i saw i
read it in the paper and that it was
that the friends reunion was happening
and i just didn't get called
isn't that weird yeah that would i think
it created that anxiety of like what if
that did happen and they're all cooking
up a show and
like a thanksgiving episode which i
always thought were my favorites yeah
and then and and what happened to rachel
yeah yeah it would be and and then they
like cast someone else in your part yeah
it's like andy and a wig or something
and people are like
what and they don't and you know yeah
that almost happened though you know at
the very beginning of friends oh is that
true
they actually had girls auditioning
because i was double booked on a
television show i was doing another show
so they and then cbs picked that show up
to sort of spite friends for three
episodes and then so i was literally
remember we took our first you know
group we were doing our first sort of
promo shots
and you know i had to stand out of like
a bunch of them but just in case they
had to slot somebody else in that is so
weird yeah it's of course now it's
impossible to think of that show without
any one of you you know what i mean it's
just it's that's impossibility yeah well
it's impossible and it never will be
possible yeah because it's over well
unless
unless someone invents a time machine
invents a time machine goes back and
yeah puts me in one of those roles
and i and i ruin it no i'm like matt
leblanc's part hey
people are like that guy's awful i don't
think you'd do leblanc
swimmer chandler
that what you see me as i'm a swimmer no
chandler
no no you're not they'd have to right
around me maybe the naked guy
i could be the naked guy and they
actually show me and it's like the
whitest nude body anyone's ever
i want this crowd to back me up uh they
thought that was funny